a rare brain infection among children is
now spiking all across the valley and
that has triggered an investigation out
from the CDC Southern Nevada saw an
increase in intracranial abscesses in
young children in fact so far 17 cases
have already been reported in patients
who are 18 years old in just the last
year I should say 18 years old and
younger in just the last year
it's exceptionally rare illness and so
the numbers that we have while they have
tripled in 2022 they're still low
numbers so there really can't be
anything that you can truly say is cause
causative
so here's what parents should be looking
for seek medical attention right away if
your child is experiencing symptoms like
severe headaches maybe changes in their
behavior even seizures slurred speech
weakness on one side of the body and
even changes in their vision